some breaking news to bring you now this
is the latest
uh from grant shaps the secretary of
state for transport
and uh bringing us the latest countries
to be
removed from the travel corridors
joining spain will be
andorra belgium and the bahamas
they say this is based on the latest
data i'll read
the tweet now it says data shows we need
to remove andorra belgium and the
bahamas
from our list of coronavirus travel
corridors in order to keep infection
rates down
if you arrive in the uk after 4 a.m on
saturday
at these destination from these
destinations you will need to
self-isolate for 14 days well let's talk
to our chief political correspondent
john craig
who joins me from westminster it was
just a couple of weeks ago john you and
i were breaking the news about spain and
of course
a little bit more notice this time for
travellers yes slightly more because uh
mr shaps is saying in his tweet if you
arrive after
4 00 a.m on saturday so not tomorrow but
the next day
this was entirely predictable we were
expecting this because of a big rise in
cases
in belgium belgium apparently has one of
the highest per capita
coronavirus death rates in the world
more than 9
800 fatalities out of a population of
about 11 million there have been a
resurgence of cases of the virus
in belgium passing 70 000 cases
this week now the government has also as
well as uh
uh slapping a quarantine order on people
returning from belgium
two weeks like the others uh uh made an
announcement uh
about to other countries andorra belgium
and the bahamas
are the three an announcement from the
department of transport in the last few
minutes
and dora belgium and the bahamas have
been removed from the list of travel
corridors
for england following data showing a
significant increase
on in confirmed cases this is a
government announcement
i've been i'm quoting from brunei and
malaysia
have been added to the list of uh travel
corridors for england
uh having been assessed by the joint
biosecurity center
as posing a lower infection risk
and the government is saying travelers
are urged to check the latest advice
from the foreign office and
before traveling will be required to
fill in a passenger locator
form before returning home so bad news
if you're coming from andorra belgium
and the bahamas
good news if you're traveling back from
brunei or malaysia
so the uh foreign office sorry the
department for transport
is also saying um there's been a
consistent
increase in kovid 19 cases per 100
000 of the population in belgium since
the middle of july
with a four-fold increase in total cases
over this time period in andorra
new cases per week have increased
five-fold over the same time period
in the bahamas the weekly case rate
peaked at 78.6
last week up from 3.1 in mid-july
i can go on brunei and malaysia have
been added to the travel corridor
following a decrease in confirmed cases
and so people from 4am on tuesday
11th of august passengers arriving in
england from these
destinations that's brunei and malaysia
will no longer need to self-isolate
so long as they haven't been in or
transited through any of the non-exempt
uh countries
uh in the 14-day preceding their arrival
so
uh a announcement from the department
for transport there about a number of
countries
so it's uh it's uh quarantine for
andorra belgium and the bahamas
no quarantine for brunei and malaysia
the first of those comes in 4 a.m
saturday brunei and malaysia that comes
in
at 4 00 am next tuesday the 11th of
august